do you think he
should not have been banned from all
these platforms i i don't
think i do think that if you are a
private company
right i do think and this is where you
run into this this problem like i don't
know
if these tech companies were government
utilities would that
decrease people's likelihood of being
banned i don't know
right so i'm i'm i
i understand the benefit of them being
treated like public utilities and people
thinking they have the right to a
twitter
i'm i've never i don't know i have very
little confidence i mean the
government's trying to roll out a
vaccine in california and we vaccinated
like five people i mean
in terms of what we need to do in the
state right so maybe if it was a
government utility i
i do think someone like alex just like
there should be some
process so if you're gonna get rid of
someone they should have a way to defend
themselves
there should be more democratic yeah
uh process that you can go through than
just being
unilaterally taken off something but
like
then you run into the you're like am i
going to say that everyone deserve no if
you're threatening or
harassing people or threatening to kill
them publishing their private
information if you're committing crimes
on these
platforms obviously the people that own
these platforms are going to be like
we're not going to allow this to happen
so i understand
that there is a line right there is some
like people that could say there's no
line aren't really thinking like there
is a line
uh i just don't that line seems to be
moving all the time
and it seems to be a very hard thing to
police but i i don't think you can
remove a guy off
everything and then also bank accounts
won't give him debit cards or credit
cards i don't know if you talk to him
about that but like
you know there were financial
institutions that were refusing to let
him
you know park his money there so i mean
it really does get
pretty terrifying pretty quickly
um probably without any transparency
from those companies
so you're right there it feels like
there should be a process
of uh just having for him to defend
himself
or i think there needs to be a process
for people to defend themselves
i i every day i wake up and i go can is
something i said in a video gonna get
taken out of context is somebody gonna
get angry
is somebody gonna be you know i say wild
stuff because that's what makes me laugh
that's what makes my friends laugh and
that's what makes my audience laugh
so i i never ever people you know
whatever
whatever political side you come down on
i think if you make your living speaking
it's always interesting to me if you are
pro
the d platforming is that's odd it's
interesting to consider
kind of a jury uh
context to where you know there's
transparency about why your video about
bombing um
disney world might be taken down like
it's
uh it gets taken down and then there is
uh it's almost like
creating a little court case a mini
court case and not in the legal sense
but in the
in the public sphere and then people
should be able to have
you know you pick representatives of our
current society and have a discussion
about that and make a
real vote you know just have like jury
locks himself up in a discussion that
kind of
that kind of process might be necessary
right now what happens
is twitter is completely first of all
they're just mostly not aware of
everything they're doing there's too
much stuff but the stuff they're aware
about
they make the decision in closed doors
uh the meetings
and without any transparency right to
the rest of the company actually but
also transparency to uh
the rest of the world and so and then
all they say is we're doing we're making
decisions because the people
they use things like violence so
violence equals bad
and if this person is quote-unquote
inciting violence therefore that gives
us enough
enough reason to ban them without any
kind of process
it's i mean it's interesting i'm i'm
torn in the whole thing
if it was indeed there's no transparency
about it but
if parlor was indeed inciting violence
like if there was brewing of violence
potential violence where you know
thousands of people
might uh die because of some kind of
riot
like the that's the scary thing about
mob
about when a lot of people get together
right
who are good people like legitimately
good people that
love this country that don't see enemies
yet
uh around them but if they get excited
together
and there's guns involved it's a problem
and then some cop
gets nervous and shoots one person
another person shoots
the cop and then there's a lot of
shooting involved and then it goes from
five people dying in the capital
to thousands of people dying in the
capital well in fairness too
to defend uh the people of cap they
didn't shoot the
cop they they bludgeoned him to death
with a fire extinguisher
yes so i do i do want to just kind of
put that out
as a as a defense of them listen i'm
sure there was some wild [ __ ] going on
on parlor and i think the problem
here's the problem right there's a lot
of people that just want to go on
these sites and say they want to kill
everyone yeah and the problem is
you know at what point do you shut them
all down like i think a lot of people
are just living in a world where they're
powerless
they don't have any political power they
don't have any economic power right
they can't throw their money around uh
they don't have health care
their their job security isn't great uh
they might be living in a community that
doesn't have the resources they would
like it to have uh
they're they're not happy and thrilled
and then they have these sites where
they can go on and just say man i'd like
to [ __ ] burn it all down
and distinguishing a guy blowing off
steam and saying wild stuff from a
genuine threat
is a very hard thing to do you know like
i
ha i've threatened to kill i got banned
from airbnb i threaten to kill the
people
um that banned me comedically
yeah comedically this is a joke i'm not
going to kill you
yeah this is a joke because i'm blowing
off steam and i'm angry
do you know how many people that my
parent like my dad's like i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill this guy my mom's like i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill yeah you know they
were talking about each other
but it's but none of it ever happened
but we should be
i think you you you have to create a
space
for people to threaten to overthrow the
government
as long as they don't violently do it
yeah i mean does that make any sense
like
i mean as long as they're not gonna go
hurt innocent people
what are you gonna do like there's so
many people out there that you that's
why a lot of these things like you know
4chan
these sites a lot of people are going on
there they just want to say the most
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
because they it's the thing that gives
them they can laugh or they can release
steam and it's
it is immature it is stupid it's not
productive it's not
you know but at the end of the day
if you're not going to give people
health insurance you got to give them
something it's like when someone in this
country dies that everyone disagrees
with right
political figure media figure a lot of
people dance on their grave online
and then everyone people goes dude and
the other side will always do it like if
a conservative dies and everyone goes
great
conservatives goes this is grotesque
that you
and then when rbg dies they all have
parties and their conservatives go great
um you have to let people in this
country
enjoy the deaths of their enemies
yeah they do because they don't have
much else
again if you gave them other things you
might say guy
you can go get an e-operation why don't
you
stop but if if they're working for [ __ ]
wages
and you haven't figured out a way to to
treat them
uh treat their cancer diagnosis and they
don't like
i mean life you know you know you gotta
have you gotta derive
pleasure from something right it's an
interesting point that anger
is a good valve like to for if
if your life is suffering that there's
something
very powerful about anger but i still
have hope that it doesn't have to be i
mean that kind of channeling into anger
that then becomes hate led us into a lot
of troubles in human history
yeah you have to be careful uh
empowering people too much in that anger
especially
i think mike i think i understand
why people were nervous about parlor
about twitter and so on sure yeah
because all that [ __ ] talking about
violence
was now paired with let's get together
at this location
right this was a new thing like it's not
just being on whatever platform
talking [ __ ] it's saying we're going to
in physical space meet and then
everybody got all these platforms got
nervous well what happens when all these
[ __ ] talkers
uh all these angry people that are just
steaming uh letting off steam
meet in the physical space uh and there
was
probably overreach uh almost definitely
overreach but i can understand why they
were nervous i agree
there doesn't seem to be and this is
when trump got elected when you have
like
whatever you have right whether you have
riots in portland in seattle where you
have the antifa people doing crazy
things you have like
you know the people storming the capital
there never seems to be a ton of
uh an examination of why these ideas are
becoming popular
why are people so angry yeah what is
leading people to this
yes why are we here what about their
lives
is to the point where they need to show
up at these places and like and now
obviously there's always going to be
people on the fringe
they'll always be the mentally unwell
they'll always be people that want to
destroy
society but when you look at how popular
large you know long discredited things
whether it's fascism
you know totalitarian communism all of
these things are like
why are they back why are they back in a
big way and why are
why are people so fed up with the status
quo
that they're finding you know solace
in the most extreme uh
discredited theories of how to run and
operate societies
theories that have led to deaths a lot
of people so to me i'm like
if those people at the capitol
yes if they were going to work if
there's
you know if they were able to go out and
drink at
chili's if they were able to
get a [ __ ] checkup right like
if their job paid a little bit better
and i'm not saying that this is all the
reason right
i'm sure that there's a lot of people
there that are doing quite well and
they're still nuts
but like the anger and the rage that's
boiling
to the surface of this society does it
come from the fact
that across the board people
in very different areas and and with
very different political beliefs
feel like they are being [ __ ] over and
there's nothing they can do about it
that's what the baseline to me
they look at the people that run the
country and run the world whether
they're
tech titans the guys that you talk to or
whether they're people that run
the government whether they're people
that run large banks
large media companies the people that
have created
this kind of you know infrastructure
that everyone lives in
these people are incredibly powerless
and when you push people to that point
logically sadly and unfortunately
the next thing does seem to be violent
you